failed former president Donald Trump in
one of his most cartoonishly bizarre
acts gave I guess you would call it a
eulogy at the funeral service of diamond
of diamond and silk her real name was
not Diamond it was anithia Lynette
Hardaway she passed away not long ago
believed to be from kovid unvaccinated
we'll get to that by the way a little
bit later Donald Trump announced in a
soaking wet and slurring statement as we
looked at earlier that he would be
presiding over it Donald Trump did not
know that this was going to go for three
hours and in fact he ended up
complaining about it but let's start
with Trump's heartwarming and emotional
tribute to Diamond
saying the prisons of many countries are
emptying out into the United States the
mental institutions of many countries
are emptying out into the United States
talk about gas prices and inflation not
a typical eulogy as one would expect you
know things we can fix inflation we can
fix so much of what's been damaged over
the last two years we had it going so
well but we can fix these things but you
know millions of people I think 15
million people they say three maybe four
I don't know I think remember a memorial
service remembering the great Diamond
this is what Trump is talking about
they have no idea how many people
and they allowed their prisons to be
emptied out into the United States of
America they allowed their mental
institutions to be emptied out into the
United States of America never happened
Common Sense would tell you that if you
had common sense you wouldn't be doing
that Mike would know that but you
wouldn't be doing this by the way
Trump's pointing to Mike pillow millions
and millions of people are coming and no
country would be able to withstand this
no country whether you're rich or poor
and we're not really rich we owe as of
this morning 31 trillion dollars right
so I don't know you call it rich I guess
I don't know maybe not this is really
helping me to mourn and grieve with the
diamonds family we spend a lot of money
on other countries and many of those
countries hate us so we give them money
so common sense would tell you all of
these things inflation was caused by
energy they stopped the energy and all
of a sudden you gasoline went from 1.87
a gallon two five six seven in
California eight dollars a gallon and
when your Baker makes his cakes and when
your hospitals create heat and all of
the different things you need this for
everything goes up and it's run away
it's far greater than people thought
this this is this is performance art I
mean uh in in a thousand years when
future sociologists and anthropologists
and psychologists want to learn about
the insanity of this era you would show
them this and you would say this was a
funeral eulogy for a woman who died
and died at a relatively young age and
this was a former president who showed
up and talked about mental institutions
so-called being emptied out into our
country
Trump then complained as he often does
he was not expecting this to go more
than three hours okay and he was not
particularly happy and and I don't
believe you know they told me he said
give me a little time because I have a
lot of people waiting for me back in a
place called Palm Beach Florida
they said give me a little time what do
you think it'll say oh about 15-20
minutes in and out
I said what could take longer this is a
little longer than 15 minutes right
yes it was I mean it is true it was
three plus hours of stories and prayers
and hymns is that how you pronounce it
hymns the n as silent
um and it took a very very long time and
Donald Trump was not particularly
pleased with that Donald Trump also
announcing to the crowd again this is
all in memory of diamond it's all out of
respect for her memory and her life and
everything Trump announcing he wanted to
ensure that there would be valet parking
at their valet service at this event
please know that we share in your grief
that's why you have such an incredible
crowd of people I said let's pick a big
place I don't care don't worry about it
just pick a big place
because uh the Trump's not paying anyway
so who cares right he'll just not pay
Apple wouldn't have held the kind of
people the number of people that we have
and uh we're doing it right and that's
the way it should be and I did notice a
big line of very very uh nice Vehicles
outside that's going to be handled
properly right so we're going to handle
it properly go out and style she knew
that go out and style folks we will be
remembering The Life and Times of
diamond and we will share in the grief
and and tragedy with her family and a
valet will be properly handling all cars
please make sure to tip make sure to tip
the valet and then just when you thought
the eulogy could not get any stranger
Trump decides to make it about himself
and with tears and tissues in the crowd
he concludes this moving tribute by
reminding the crowd that the 2020
election was stolen from him how do we
stop the cheating how do we stop it
where you get more votes but you still
don't win and the answer is the
Republicans have to get tougher yeah the
top people have to get tougher right and
and you have to really swap them there's
a level at which even they can't produce
and so if you win big enough you're
going to get there and then once we're
there we're going to straighten it all
out and get it back to where it was but
yeah
um Saturday Night Live could do nothing
with this because this is already like
part 20 of a Saturday Night Live skit
unbelievable unbelievable it's it's a
sort of Genius parody avant-garde
performance uh art of some way it's
kafka-esque it's delusional it's
hilarious it's sad it's a tragic comedy
um unbelievable and listen Trump
deserves some credit in the sense that
it was hard to imagine even Trump
turning this event into something so
absurd and unable to be parodied but he
was able to do it now let's move on to
the shedding vaccine conspiracy that
came from this event
as many people know I'm a white ale type
of guy when it comes to beer and even
for those of us who drink responsibly
like me sometimes you still feel it the
next day and it can slow you down
especially when you start to get up
there in the years like me check out our
sponsor zebiotics which is a probiotic
drink that breaks down the byproduct of
alcohol responsible for those rough
mornings after drinking all you do is
drink a tiny bottle of zebiotics before
you have alcohol next day you'll feel
refreshed and ready to go the way it
works is when you drink a toxic
byproduct builds up in your gut and
that's what causes you to feel bad the
next day zibiotics produces an enzyme to
break down that byproduct and zibiotic
stands by their product 100 if it
doesn't work for you you get all your
money back no questions asked remember
we're talking about drinking responsibly
here I can't more highly prioritize
getting a good night's sleep zibiotics
is for responsible drinkers who just
just want to get the most out of the
next day go to zebiotics.com Pacman get
15 off your first order with the code
Pacman the link is down below